The N64 upside down looks like a koala's face.
And here's a wall that changes color
when you pee on it.
Vsauce. Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
This jet pack of sorts just set a
record by flying for seven straight
minutes.
The company claims their current model
can carry a 250-pound man for half an
hour
at a max speed of 60 miles per hour.
But if you prefer to sit down while you
travel, try out his motorized
easy chair.
It's just a prototype, so you can't buy it.
Or this monster.
It's a 1000 watt subwoofer chair
with two 16-inch subwoofers and it can
connect the iPods
or gaming consoles.
Apparently some people like to sit on recycled
computer parts
with Ethernet and ribbon woven seats encased frame.
And others like to sit on... wow.
The flexible
love seat incorporates an accordion
like honeycomb structure
made from recycled paper and wood.
It's kind of like a slinky for your
butt.
Get ready for summer with the Nerf
Thunderstorm. It's a battery-powered
super soakers, so you don't need to pump it
and it has interchangeable clips of water.
You could stay inside all summer
and just build a giant Lego wall.
You'll need 270,000 legos
and probably a bodyguard with a Lego ARC gun from
District 9.
Or stay inside for thirty years and build
a toothpick sculpture of San Francisco.
There are
eight paths for ping pong balls to
travel along as they tore this incredibly
intricate creation.
Quick challenge.
Listen to this music box and see if you
recognize the song.
Time's up.
Here's the mega answer.
This is a prototype of a screen that
follows your
eye movements. By using a webcam with face
tracking software,
the idea is to make games like
first-person shooters seem even more
immersive.
And to make kissing less immersive,
here's a kissing transmission device.
Basically you make out with his strong
looking thing
and it transmits the data to affect the
other straw looking
thing and...
Guy getting struck by lightning.
A Russian figure skating couple won
a silver medal
thanks to their plumber-themed routine.
Finally here's an absolutely epic record-setting
Beatmania performance.
I'm gonna leave you with a riddle.
"Only one color but not one size
Stuck at the bottom yet easily flies
Present in sun but not in rain
Doing no harm and feeling no pain
What is it?"
The genius of the week is going to be a number
scavenger hunt.
Here's how it works.
I've given 5 clues,
each clue leads to a number.
Three clues are on this page.
One clue is at Facebook.com/VsauceGaming.
And the final clue is in 'Weirdos of the
Month #2.'
Find all five clues, add up all the
numbers and give us your answer.
Leave it in the comments below and I'll
give you a hint for the clue in 'Weirdoes #2.'
Eurovision.
Good luck.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Vsauce.
Announcement time. First things first, we've
got a brand new video on Vsauce2
that's a little bit different.
It's a conversation with myself in a group
called
'Underbelly' where they share with me some creepy
Pokemon facts.
They're really knowledgeable, I think you'll enjoy it.
Speaking of you, it's about time you got rewarded
more. And so, over the next few months,
Vsauce is going to be expanding genius of
the week
to include more slots.
On our channel page right now we've got two.
One is the Genius of the Week that Kevin already
mentioned, but the second one is a brand
new title called
'Sauciest of the Week.'
This is for someone who suggested something really
cool to Vsauce.
Whether it was a private message or on
Facebook, whether it was an online game or
a cool
image or something to buy, or just a hilarious comment.
Now, for the first week I chose 'sofusser,'
because of all the cool things he made with
stuff that we recommended on DONG.
But here's the excellent part.
Each week the current winner
picks next week's winner. So, 'sofusser,' if you're out there watching and you see
something over the next week that was
suggested to us or someone put something
on Facebook you think is cool,
let us know. Send us a YouTube message and
let us know who you think should be the
next week's winner.
And then that winner will pick the week after
that. So every winner gets to pass
the crown.
It should be pretty fun to see what happens.
And, hey guys,
as always,
thanks for watching.